Hello everybody my name's Lloyd Esler I've
always had a bit of an interest in cemeteries and
dead things and interesting stories around
early Southland and if you want to come along
to the eastern cemetery 6.30pm on the 4th of
November having a bit of a walk around here for
about an hour and looking at some of the
interesting graves and a few of the stories
from some of the Southland pioneers. So everybody
welcome to come along to that we're just standing
beside a grave here this is the McNab grave and
uh one of the early ones here so it's Alexander
and Janet McNab but the the um this is the tomb
also of Robert McNab who is a member of parliament
and uh well known as the author of a couple of
very important books on Southland one of them
is The Old Whaling Days and Murihiku which was
very valuable bit of early research. Robert was the
survivor of a family he was the oldest
child while he was away at school
um this is in 1871 all his siblings died they
caught a disease and within a few days there was
there's four or five children all
died so he ended up being the only child
one of the tragedies of the early years but
not particularly uncommon because medical
practice was a bit primitive there
were lots of dangerous things a lot
of people got drowned in those days and
of course there was infectious diseases so
um glad we got one survivor out of the McNab
family to make a contribution to Southland history